we got a taste of this film yesterday
did you get to see it yet we haven't
seen it it is good it's very good what
was it like for you to see the script
for the first time what was the selling
point for you that you knew this was
going to be great I loved the idea of
well the the story is so detailed and
and the the reasoning the dete the the
details in the location the details in
the character everything I loved it and
I was confused and I had to keep going I
had to go back and look at things and
understand it better and every time I
reread it I learned more and and I liked
the idea of playing a woman who's whose
harsh and tough and
very like a real force of nature yeah
but you went from 50 shades to Suspiria
which is I guess it's a thriller horror
kind of film I heard people can't even
watch it and then to this film like how
did you get through all the different
genres was that did you need therapy
with that to go from one to another
there was a little therapy yeah yeah
but there it I truly feel very lucky
that that this has been the range of
past couple years I've gotten to
experience a lot of different worlds and
learn a lot and it was the difference in
these projects it's very vast but so fun
crazy but it's so fun now your accent
was a big surprise John the minute we
see the trailer there's that thick
southern accent going on so did that
just come naturally to you or did you
have to learn the act it took a little
work I've spent some time in the south
but it's it's you want to be specific as
you can with that kind of stuff for us
it just seems like a caricature so there
were stuff as somebody I've worked with
to make it as specific as we could but
yeah it's a it's a it's fun that kind of
stuff is fun to do because it I think
it's unexpected for there's a lot of
stuff unexpected in this film there's a
lot of secrets involved in this film are
you good at keeping secrets I'm pretty
good at keeping secrets
yeah yeah I mean
yeah you yeah I'm a woman would you ever
consider that on a date night is that
something you like to do grill our films
on abatement yeah sure I like movies all
the time yeah mostly I like ones that
are just original like that aren't kind
of the same thing over and over again
and this is this is definitely an
original one-off it's not based on any
existing property it's just its own
thing and it's a very cool story told in
a very cool way yeah one of the things I
noticed when we were watching is that we
tend to be paranoid I mean this is set
in the 60s and we're seeing what happens
in motel and there's been cases that
it's happened where people are watching
guests in there in their hotel rooms are
you paranoid do you ever close your door
twice or check things twice or do you
find you're just confident with
everything around you in hotels or
animals at home do you find yourself a
little bit paranoid at home I'm not so
much if I've been gone for a long time
and I come home and if I'm alone in the
house it's I get scared I may make sure
the alarm is that all the time but I
mostly get paranoid at hotels do ya of
what just voice other people yeah yeah
people don't have a sense of privacy or
respective boundaries anymore so it's
now that everyone has like a video
camera on them at all times they think
it's okay to just take pictures of
whatever they can whenever they can and
it's it's a weird feeling because you
constantly have a sensation of like okay
I hope nobody's doing that and if they
are there's nothing I can do
yeah it's it's a really weird thing
because don't you like don't you feel
weird I feel weird if I ever try to take
a sneaky picture of somebody yeah mostly
it'd be like of somebody else's dog
but and that makes me feel weird there's
never really a time where I'm like
adults we gotta take a picture of that
person but it's like you know do you see
someone's shoes I'm just following up
with your answer your answer do you feel
violated when that happens
yeah time it's gross yes especially
because you hope that that's not gonna
get monetized in some way or sold to
some weird thing yeah but it is always
it must end I never I never will say
like I see what you're doing stop doing
that no because I don't want to
embarrass somebody so then I just take
it I just take it if I see it I'll say
something if you see something say if I
see something I say something yeah I
need to
I guess grow a pair please don't yeah
you're really you told me to just go
make your clothes really try to grow up
pants gonna make your clothes fit weird
it's telling you that's get new clothes
well that no thank you very much